[Música]
[Aplausos]
Bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
de France 24 que los invita a dar una
vuelta al mundo de la mano de nuestra
red de periodistas Berlín recibió
finalmente la petición de autorización
por parte de Polonia para exportar
tanques lepardoso de fabricación alemana
a Ucrania que ha reclamado durante meses
a occidente el envío de este tipo de
armamento para intentar recuperar las
zonas ocupadas por Rusia en el sur más
del 60% de la provincia de saporilla ha
quedado bajo el poder de las fuerzas
rusas desde el comienzo de la invasión
Moscú reclama esta provincia como parte
de su territorio después de realizar
referéndos considerados y legales para
reclamar como suyas varias provincias
ucranianas parcialmente ocupadas
nuestros enviados especiales a Ucrania
tuvieron acceso a las labores de la
brigada 110 de las tropas ucranianas
informe de Catalina
esta puerta en medio de la nada lleva el
túnel que los hombres de la brigada 110
han convertido en su centro de
operaciones tienen como responsabilidad
la defensa de una de las posiciones del
frente sur de la provincia de saporilla
que después de meses de una relativa
calma ha vuelto a reactivarse en los
últimos días
la imagen que captura uno de los drones
señala como un grupo de integrantes de
las fuerzas rusas intentan avanzar y
tomar una posición
los drones son fundamentales Sin ellos
estamos ciegos
comparte esta información con las otras
unidades para que actúen e impidan que
sigan avanzando
en ciertos lugares el enemigo tiene
deseos de romper las líneas sus intentos
no han sido exitosos hasta ahora
ellos han tenido pérdidas mucho mayores
que las nuestras en este frente
los hombres reconocen que lo más
complicado de esta posición es el
terreno plano donde hay pocos lugares
para esconderse estas dificultades
quedan en evidencia en el camino a
visitar a una de las unidades que horas
antes fue atacada
algunas veces es más ruidoso otras
silencioso usted puede sentirlo
este grupo de hombres la mayoría cosacos
los une que son originarios de esta
provincia de zaporilla que tiene más del
60% de su territorio bajo el control
ruso muchos de ellos tienen todavía
familias en territorios ocupados como
pueden ver están atacando tratan de
entrar nosotros estamos defendiendo el
comandante prefiere continuar la
conversación en el interior
los hombres Bajo su cargo confirman que
los rusos han movilizado un gran número
de tropas en este frente a nosotros
también nos han reforzado y somos más
fuertes no es lo mismo en el comienzo
tenemos más experiencia estamos más
Unidos
desafortunadamente parte del personal de
batalla ha quedado herido o ha muerto y
este hecho nos deja una huella que nos
acompañará hasta el final tenemos que
seguir luchando por nosotros y ellos a
pesar de las dificultades estos hombres
repiten que la única opción que tienen
en esta guerra es seguir adelante
el régimen iraní se está volviendo cada
vez más violento a la hora de intentar
sofocar un movimiento de protesta
liderado por mujeres a raíz de la muerte
de maxa de Mini el 16 de septiembre en
los últimos cuatro meses ha muerto más
de 500 personas mientras que varios de
los manifestantes han sido condenados a
muerte y varios de ellos ejecutados a
pesar de las protestas por parte de la
comunidad internacional podrán estas
tácticas de intimidación aplacar el
movimiento de protesta o por el
contrario aumentarán aún más la ira
nuestros colegas de Olivia bis fueron al
terreno para discutir con mujeres
a pesar del frío las iraníes encuentran
formas creativas de continuar su lucha
por la libertad
en las calles de Teherán el domingo por
la tarde incluso esta pelea con bolas de
nieve es un acto de protesta Estas
mujeres están en la calle y no llevan el
velo en la cabeza por ello podrían
enfrentarse hasta 10 años de cárcel
no Me cubro el pelo porque creo que es
lo menos que podemos hacer hemos hecho
algunos cambios positivos solo estamos
al principio siempre me pongo el velo
alrededor del cuello Así que si siento
peligro puedo cubrirme la cabeza porque
temo por mi familia
[Aplausos]
al narrar lo que ocurre sobre el terreno
las iraníes ponen en peligro sus vidas
para hablar con esta activista
utilizamos un sistema especial de
videochat cifrado en el despacho de un
abogado parisino
decidimos cambiar nuestra forma de
protestar la represión ha sido muy
agresiva y ha muerto demasiada gente
hemos transformado los funerales de los
condenados a muerte En plataformas
políticas hemos estado imprimiendo
panfletos y distribuyéndolos por las
calles y si el régimen nos pide que
hagamos algo hacemos Exactamente lo
contrario
los simulacros de juicios y las
ejecuciones no han hecho más que avivar
la ira
no tenemos tiempo para llorar cada vez
que perdemos a alguien cercano nos hace
más fuertes todos estamos atrapados en
esto todos tenemos miedo pero no hay
vuelta atrás creemos que funcionará
sabemos que debemos derrocar al régimen
y llegar hasta el final
está dispuesta a arriesgar su vida ya lo
estoy haciendo
las protestas han ido mucho más allá de
los derechos de la mujer la gente
también está enfadada por la grave
situación económica incluso las mujeres
conservadoras se están levantando
no estoy de acuerdo con las autoridades
Dios no es tan Injusto como para
castigarnos simplemente por llevar un
velo en la cabeza debemos ser libres se
está produciendo un cambio un gran
cambio de mentalidad es una revolución
las autoridades han intensificado su
mortal represión y han culpado a los
manifestantes de la desastrosa situación
económica del país
Brasil registra tres denuncias de
intolerancia religiosa por día solo en
el primer semestre de 2022 fueron
contabilizadas 545 quejas la mayoría en
las ciudades de Sao Paulo y Río de
Janeiro los más afectados son los
practicantes de las religiones
afrodescendientes lo que para muchos
evidencia un problema estructural de la
sociedad brasileña misma sin embargo en
las iglesias evangélicas dominantes hay
quienes luchan por poner fin a estos
actos de violencia informe de Valeria y
amindidara
Hoy es Día de rezo en este templo
dedicado al candomblé es una religión
que llegó a Brasil de la mano de los más
de 5 millones de esclavos africanos
estamos en la mallada fluminense en la
periferia de Río de Janeiro donde reina
el miedo tras una ola de ataques
violentos contra terrenos como llaman a
esos templos los autores son
narcotraficantes convertidos a la
religión evangélica
son personas que dicen no quiero que el
[__] viva más aquí ahora quien vive
aquí es Dios nosotros seríamos el
demonio
esta religiosa da voz a quienes están
amenazados de muerte a pesar de su
perfil militante reconoce que tiene
miedo
mis amigos me dicen hermana sal de aquí
esto es peligroso no sigas denunciando
los ataques
para este estudioso detrás de la
intolerancia religiosa está el racismo
estructural
Este es un proyecto de estado es un
proyecto político hegemónico que quiere
que los cristianos sean hegemónicos que
sean la comunidad que pueda gozar de
todos sus derechos mientras que las
otras religiones como el espiritismo la
onda y el candomblé están fuera de ese
proyecto
pero un sector de los evangélicos se
opone a tanta violencia
klever es una estrella de la música
gospel cantó la investidura del
presidente Lula su apoyo explícito a las
religiones de matriz africana le ha
costado varios ataques por partes de sus
fans antes de ser cristianos soy un
hombre negro que creció en una Favela yo
fui criado en un ambiente muy plural
desde el momento en que veo en la
sociedad siendo una figura pública
templos atacados Víctimas de la
intolerancia religiosa no puedo quedarme
callado
es el ejemplo vivo de que no todos los
evangélicos son intolerantes ni se
identifican con el fundamentalismo
religioso
Reino Unido es un país que afronta
dificultades Su economía se ha visto
afectada por los efectos del brexit y
como muchas otras naciones del mundo ha
resultado golpeada por la inflación y la
crisis energética derivada de la Guerra
de Ucrania el resultado es un profundo
descontento social que se ha traducido
en largas de múltiples sectores
incluyendo el de la salud uno de los
grandes orgullos de la sociedad
británica después de las enfermeras los
conductores de ambulancias se unieron al
paro para exigir mejores condiciones
laborales juliance y cluscas Alí fueron
a Londres para encontrarlos
lleva 27 años recorriendo Londres en su
ambulancia Steve entrará en huelga
regañadientes
no me metí en ese trabajo para hacer una
huelga sino para ayudar a la gente pero
la falta de financiación y los bajos
aumentos salariales hacen que haya
decenas de miles de puestos de trabajos
sin cubrir en el nhs es fantástico el
apoyo de la gente en estos momentos es
reconfortante incluso conmovedor
[Música]
se unió al equipo en plena crisis del
covid 19 esta joven trabajadora ha visto
cómo se deterioraba el sistema sanitario
desde su llegada los retrasos para que
acudan los paramédicos son cada vez
mayores y este invierno ha habido récord
en las listas de espera con hospitales
saturados
el real colegio de médicos afirma que se
producen 500 muertes a la semana debido
a los largos retrasos tenemos historias
terribles horribles de pacientes que
esperan en camas de hospital durante
diez doce horas no es aceptable
sabes que es duro pensar que puedes
esperar horas y horas y tu paciente
puede empeorar y no puedes hacer nada
para ayudarlo
empieza el día y enseguida entra una
llamada
vale tenemos trabajo que hacer es
Alguien que ha perdido el conocimiento
Steve y están listos como siempre
equipos como este piden más recursos
para salvar vidas en un clamor sin
precedentes en Reino Unido
Gracias por seguir un nuevo episodio de
corresponsales nos damos cita la próxima
semana siga con más información en
France 24 y 24 punto com